or last time that you kind of allowed
yourself an evening you have to get more
crazy letting loose for me but at 6:45
in the morning she's awakened so high so
they don't care that I let loose the
night before so I don't lose so much in
the spirit of bad moms ETH at with the
cast at CinemaCon went from partying to
all about mommy hood now
Mila as the newest mom of the group here
how has a house becoming a mother you
can change you the mush yeah we
prioritize my life and I want to see
like I travel to all my 20s and I was
very selfish I don't like to say that in
a good way
not like in a way that I regret it a
great way and I think having a kid made
me realize how incredibly selfless I
want to be and I think that that's what
that made me do and it's big yeah that's
great
it's but it does change the way you look
at at life and what you doing is
something worth doing instead of being
with your kids I think it does
it's good inside and you can hear it as
a soon-to-be parent people tell you but
then when it happens there's nothing
like the experience nothing I definitely
I would never trade it for them I mean
truly like ever ever ever but I know
that when we decided to have a kid we
were ready to no longer be selfish I
mean at least start the process again
neatly as humans for very selfish people
if you really wanted to have a fan
and so I think the bad having this
little human to raise we're still
balancing act and you learn how to be
like a great partner and a great wife
and a great well man and be yourself and
still be responsible for you know a
living child or